it wasn't quite the result they'd hoped
for but the Sweden Democrats stole
significant ground in this election and
its supporters were keen to advertise
their success cheering the man who drove
the narrative of recent roots and
persuaded so many Swedish voters to
switch their allegiance and Jimmy
oakerson feels emboldened the Sweden
Democrats he insisted are the fresh
thoughts in politics do you know what's
Friends of Sweden they said on the TV
that it's hard to declare a winner of
this election I know who has won this
election it's the Sweden Democrats he
wants to talk to the main political
leaders in Sweden who have so far
shunned cooperation with his hardline
anti-immigrant movement but many voters
didn't propelling the party into
promising territory supporter sense the
opportunity warning of a backlash if the
party success is ignored I think if they
don't speak with us
they're gonna have big problems in the
future and then you know this Sweden
Swedish Democrats is just going to
continue growing this is the people
we're the party of the people this is
two or three million people in Sweden
saying enough we need to change and
change is what this man is resisting
Prime Minister Stefan lurvin
pushing back against calls to go afters
parties worse results in a century
leaving his center-left coalition neck
and neck with the center-right bloc but
he won't be looking to the Sweden
Democrats for help a party he is
condemned as racist please the obese
vegan but of course I'm disappointed by
the fact that the party will not see
roots could gain so much groans they
have no budget that will work no
improvements that will make life easier
for people the only thing they could
offer is a widening gap in society and
growing hatred the election results
followed a European trend of traditional
parties being shaken by the far right
and the center-right alliance also
suffered the Sweden Democrats are hoping
for a quick meeting with the leader of
the bloc's biggest party but he too has
up to now rejected cooperation which
leads Swedish politics in a state of
turmoil and this man hoping in time he
will have a hand to play Michele
Clifford Sky News Sweden